c'est un festival taillé sur mesure pour
se réapproprier son patrimoine
d'abord culinaire avec la découverte et
la dégustation de produits marqués
labellisés bio aux épices et au miel
alors vous avez les carottes de l'amande
les courgettes excellent madame vraiment
la viande est tendre et puis c'est du
bon on sent le travail paye à un ou deux
mais loin tu es pia au pays
il y à de nombreuses années ces hommes
et ces femmes ont marqué l'histoire
on apprend ici l'origine de chaque tenue
et le rôle de chaque personnage sur les
habitations replonger dans l'histoire
aujourd'hui semble de plus en plus
nécessaire on a une histoire qui est à
la fois riche qui est douloureuse qui
est complexe mais qui est mécanique mais
qui est extraordinaire et c'est en
l'expliquant en raccrochant ce qui peut
être
l'élément du folklore à un élément
historique qu'on replace les choses me
font n'avons gravement besoin en ce
moment
l'histoire raconte aussi que le premier
plan de café des antilles a été
entretenue en martinique avant d'être
planté ailleurs martinique terre
d'histoire terre où la nature se montre
généreuse sur le site une biodiversité
un écosystème sur lequel un sentier de 4
km a été aménagé l'occasion de
s'enfoncer dans la nature
c'est un domaine il faudrait que les
gens se réapproprient ça vraiment toute
la diversité naturelle de la martinique
réunis sur le même site et le jardin
remarquable en 2016 le domaine
d'émeraude est aujourd'hui candidat au
patrimoine mondial de l'unesco
le site labellisé patrimoine mondial
unesco
ces quatre à six froid de visiteurs qui
viennent chaque année et ça constitue
une embellie sur le plan de économique
le plan dolman l'emploi et si ce que
nous voulons faire pour le territoire
nord de la martinique
un territoire nord d'évasion d'aventuré
et de découverte de nombreux atouts une
note positive pour le développement
touristique de la martinique
[Musique]